et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Laurent Jacoby bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous députés de la Moselle
du rassemblement national on est
ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
régionale représentée par Christelle
Bertrand du groupe La Dépêche bonjour
Christelle bonjour Oriane bonjour
Laurent
jacobelli on commence en parlant foot le
match France - Maroc qui allait une de
beaucoup de nos quotidiens régionaux ce
matin Emmanuel Macron sera ce soir au
Qatar pour se tenir les Bleus est-ce
qu'il a raison oh écoutez la place du
président de la République est là où il
pense qu'il doit être vous savez il va
soutenir l'équipe de France ça paraît
assez naturel il n'y serait pas allé que
n'aurait-on pas dit la question qui se
pose c'est pourquoi cette Coupe du Monde
a lieu au Qatar il faut remonter une
décennie en arrière essayer de
comprendre faire une enquête précise
pour se dire comment une coupe du monde
a lieu en plein hiver dans un pays qui
n'a pas une culture footballistique
incroyable qu'est-ce qui a fait qu'elle
est élément magique a fait que la Coupe
du Monde se passe au Qatar là il y a une
vraie question surtout dans l'ambiance
actuelle disons-le où on voit que le
Qatar
semblerait avoir envie d'influer sur les
décisions par tous les moyens qu'il a en
sa possession notamment l'argent on va
revenir là-dessus mais donc Emmanuel
Macron il a raison
a-t-il personnellement je ne suis pas
président de la République il est
président de la République il va
soutenir l'équipe de France je pense
qu'il y a assez de sujets il y a assez
de sujets polémiques par rapport au
Qatar et par rapport à cette coupe du
monde pour aller en chercher où il y en
a pas forcément est-ce qu'il doit faire
une déclaration ou un geste de principe
pour prendre ces distances par rapport à
la manière dont les choses ont été
organisées pour cette coupe du monde
notamment on a parlé du nombre de morts
sur les chantiers sur les stades il y a
eu 6500 morts sur les chantiers il y a
une situation politique au Qatar qui est
assez inacceptable sur le droit des
femmes sur le droit des homosexuels sur
la liberté d'expression en général le
cathares qui vous le savez finance des
associations sur notre territoire qui
sont
islamiste on peut le dire il y a une
volonté de répandre l'islamisme partout
dans le monde du Qatar et ça ce sont des
vraies questions le président de la
République doit se prononcer et doit
avoir une position forte et ferme de la
France mais on voit qu'à chaque fois
qu'on parle du Qatar et bien les grandes
convictions sur les droits de l'homme
les grandes convictions sur le droit des
minorités ça faiblisse se réduisent
comme peau de chagrin là encore c'est
très étonnant justement vous parliez du
Qatar qui est au Colt au coeur pardon
d'un scandale de corruption présumé au
Parlement européen la députée grecque a
été écrouée est-ce que pour vous on est
dans une faute individuelle enfin il
faut être présumer individuelle où
est-ce que c'est un scandale qui entasse
le Parlement oui ça entachent le
Parlement disons-le ces gens qui en
permanence quel que soit les organes
d'ailleurs il y a l'Union européenne
donne des leçons de droits de l'homme à
la terre entière critique telle et tel
régime critique même tel est-elle partie
politique c'est grand donneur de leçons
lorsque il y a l'odeur du pétrole et de
l'argent semble un peu plus souple donc
il va falloir généralisez-vous je dis
que il y a là-bas à Bruxelles une
puissance des lobbies il y a une
perméabilité entre les intérêts privés
et l'intérêt général qui ne me semble
pas bonne une fois encore il va falloir
faire des enquêtes précises notamment
auprès vous dites c'est une députée a
été vice-présidente donc c'est quelqu'un
qui était dans l'exécutif de ce
Parlement il va falloir regarder ce qui
se passe dans le groupe socialiste là
encore à les donneurs de leçons une fois
que il y a des valises de billets
semblent un peu plus souples on verra
bien ce que dira l'enquête mais je pense
qu'il faut aller voir ce que peut faire
la justice et puis j'entends parler d'un
organisme qui serait une émanation du
Parlement ou de la Commission européenne
pour enquêter sur ces sujets non il faut
que ça soit la justice qui fasse son
affaire et une fois encore Bruxelles il
n'empêche pas l'enquête interne ou non
mais il peut y avoir une enquête interne
vous savez l'enquête interne faite par
des gens qui vont juger leur père moi je
suis toujours un petit peu un petit peu
inquiet mais je suis
heureux qu'il y ait des enquêtes vous
savez nous à l'Assemblée nationale nous
avons demandé une commission d'enquête
sur les ingérences étrangères parce que
parlons franchement c'est une commission
d'enquête interne là pour le coup oui
tout à fait mais elle est importante je
vais vous dire pourquoi parce que ça
fait des années quatre coups de Rago à
coups de propos malveillants on essaie
de sous-entendre que le rassemblement
national sera lié à des puissances
étrangères jamais le début du
commencement d'une preuve et bien alors
mettons carte sur table enquêtons mais
surtout les partis politiques et surtout
les influences étrangères et on verra
vous avez une idée précise quand vous
dites tous les partis politiques par
exemple si le Qatar mais nous verrons
bien par exemple si le Qatar a des liens
avec certains paradis politiques si la
Chine a des liens avec certains partis
politiques et jusqu'à quel point mais
c'est important les renaissances quand
vous dites personne pour avoir fait
l'objet dans nos partis politiques dans
lequel je suis
membre et élu pour avoir fait l'objet de
critique sans preuve je ne vais pas
faire la même chose sur les autres je
pense que simplement il y a une
suspicion générale il y a le volet du
doute
qu'elles en disent vous mettre sur cette
sur cette voie là mais je vous dis parce
que nous avons fait nous l'objet de
critique et donc il y a un moment on
peut pas se fier que aux rumeurs ou
orago le
Qatar finance en France des associations
proches des Frères musulmans il faut le
dire on voit bien que le Qatar à chaque
fois qu'il s'agit de prendre une
décision économique ou politique fait
l'objet d'une clémence que d'autres pays
n'ont pas alors est-ce à cause de notre
dépendance énergétique est-ce à cause de
notre dépendance énergétique qui amène à
supporter l'insupportable c'est une
possibilité est-ce qu'il y a d'autres
voix qui font que le Qatar a des réseaux
d'influence en France ils font encore il
n'est pas question ici de jeter
l'opprobre ou la suspicion sur quoi que
ce soit il faut faire une enquête
important à l'aune de ce qu'on vient de
voir au Parlement européen l'Élysée dit
ça a dit il faut que nous puissions
acquérir une incertaine forme
d'indépendance énergétique pour pouvoir
dire non au Qatar il y a d'autres pays
dont aujourd'hui on dépend est-ce que
c'est là la clé bien sûr c'est une clé
importante c'est vrai sur l'énergie
c'est vrai sur le médicament aussi parce
que vous voyez qu'aujourd'hui on est en
pénurie d'un certain nombre de
médicaments et donc les pays producteurs
pourraient avoir une influence exagérée
sur les décisions politiques françaises
c'est vrai d'une manière générale sur
toutes les industries il faut retrouver
notre souveraineté la mondialisation
la mondialisation a fait en sorte que le
pouvoir décisionnel et
éparpillé partout dans le monde et
certains aujourd'hui des leviers sur la
France qui est qui sont si vous regardez
un peu trop près ce qui se passe chez
nous il y aura une pénurie chez vous ce
système de chantage permanent n'est pas
possible ni avec le Qatar ni avec
personne d'autre cette commission
d'enquête quand allez-vous commencer à
travailler est-ce que vous savez déjà
qui vous allez auditionner alors pour
l'instant c'est Jean-Philippe Tanguy qui
sera le président de cette commission
d'enquête qui est un député du
rassemblement national je n'ai pour
l'instant pas les détails mais nous
additionnerons tout le monde les
responsables de partis politiques pour
voir ce qui se passe et bien évidemment
aussi probablement des responsables
diplomatiques de pays étrangers
sur le France Maroc de ce soir Gérald
Darmanin annoncé un dispositif policier
10000 policiers dans toute la France
dont 5000 Paris est dans la région
est-ce que c'est un bon dispositif mais
d'abord vous voyez qu'on parle d'un
match de football et tout de suite on
parle force de police moi j'aurais envie
de vous dire ce soir je serai devant mon
poste à espérer la victoire de l'équipe
de France qui fait un très beau parcours
avec une belle équipe et un entraîneur
un coach comme on dit mais si bien sûr
mais là le fait qu'on se pose la
question est quand même révélateur de
quelque chose ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que en dehors des supporters qui de
bonne foi avec coeur avec passion vont
supporter leur équipe et je fais aucun
aucune confusion il y a des gens
probablement on l'imagine qu'ils vont
descendre dans la rue n'ont pas pour
fêter une victoire mais pour casser pour
agresser des policiers voir agresser des
passants ça s'est passé à chaque fois
que l'Algérie ou le Maroc était dans une
compétition et je le redis bien il y a
des gens qui vont avoir une loi une joie
uniquement légitime écouter il se trouve
qu'hier par exemple il y avait des
argentins qui défilaient pour la
victoire de la en France avec
l'Angleterre par exemple je suis pas
simplement
pas tourner autour du pot derrière cette
question des hooligans et des supporters
des agressions dans la rue se cachent
une question qui est le modèle de
l'assimilation française il y a
aujourd'hui et je ne généralise pas mais
il y a aujourd'hui des gens d'origine
étrangère qui sont français mais qui se
sentent de cœur d'ailleurs et de papier
d'ici et bien ça pose un problème ça
pose un problème encore plus fort
lorsqu'ils essaient de régler des
comptes historiques j'allais dire que
cette histoire de repentance débouche
sur de l'agressivité l'agressivité
contre ce qui représente les symboles de
la France et de l'autorité française la
police
ce sont les supporters britanniques qui
ont posé problème et il y avait pas
est-ce que vous ce que vous soulignez
aujourd'hui on peut faire semblant de ne
pas voir la réalité à chaque fois à
chaque fois qu'il y a un match qui
concerne un certain nombre de
communautés qui pour la plupart sont
bien intégrés mais pour certains sont
mal intégrés en France et bien il y a
des leur demande en certaines cités ou
sur les Champs-Elysées on peut faire
comme si ça n'existait pas où on peut
décrire la réalité quand l'OM rencontre
le parti le Paris Saint-Germain enfin
si vous voulez si vous ne remarquez pas
moi je vais vous le dire en tout cas et
je vous emmènerai avec moi dans
certaines banlieues si vous ne remarquez
pas que dans certaines banlieues il y a
un problème de communautarisme il y a un
problème d'identification non pas à la
France mais un pays d'origine que
parfois d'ailleurs les personnes dont on
parle n'ont jamais vu ou dans lesquelles
ils ne sont jamais allés tout simplement
parce qu'il y a un rejet du modèle
français et de la France si vous ne le
voyez pas alors c'est grave parce que
tous les Français l'ont vu et donc ça
veut dire qu'il faut rebattre les cartes
de la politique de l'immigration en
France et de la politique de
l'assimilation une fois encore quand on
vient en France
on adopte les valeurs et les lois de la
France et on aime la France on ne vient
pas en France que pour des raisons
utilitaires ou financières et donc c'est
cette adhésion
au projet national dont on voit bien que
de nouvelles générations issues de
l'immigration ne participent pas
justement puisque au palais
d'immigrations
pour présenter les grandes lignes de son
projet d'immigration elle a fait le même
exercice devant les députés la semaine
dernière alors elle a répété ce qu'elle
vous a dit que ce n'était pas un projet
de régularisation massive il y a des
mesures de fermeté pour faciliter les
expulsions dire qui on ne veut pas et
qui on ne peut pas accueillir c'est ce
qu'elle a dit pourquoi vous opposez à ce
texte
sans nom soit d'un cynisme imprononçable
quand on ne contrôle pas ses frontières
comme c'est le cas de la France qui a
donné les clés à Frontex qui n'est pas
là pour contrôler mais pour accueillir
et bien quand on ne contrôle pas ses
frontières on ne contrôle pas qui rentre
et qui sort alors elle va probablement
nous proposer des textes qui encadrent
entre guillemets le droit de certains de
ces établir en France et le rejet de ce
droit pour d'autres mais comme tout le
monde peut entrer en France et qu'une
fois qu'on est en France on en parle
plus et bien tout cela c'est du vent
c'est du pipeau aujourd'hui il faut à
nouveau une fois qu'on rentre en France
on en parle plus c'est parce que dit le
texte puisque justement le texte visa
facilité les expulsions non non ce texte
vise à faciliter à faciliter la
prononciation d'obligation de quitter le
territoire français mais pas les
exécutions malheureusement parce qu'il y
a un manque de volonté aujourd'hui il y
a un étranger frappé d’occ qtf comme on
dit sur 10 qui part les autres restent
en France donc
le chiffre qui va augmenter le chien
possible de qtf c'est pas fait pour
danser sur la table il peut dire qu'ils
sont méchants et qu'il y a des gentils
comme il l'a fait mais c'est pas ça le
problème le problème c'est de négocier
avec les pays d'origine le retour tant
que cela ne sera pas fait ça ne servira
à rien
de grave blocages bien sûr vous avez
raison on fait un bras de fer on dit
c'est simple vous avez une aide au
développement si vous ne reprenez pas
vos ressortissants elle s'arrête il y a
un certain nombre de visa apparents si
vous ne reprenez
au moment où un Français sur trois
renonce aux soins je ne le crois pas
est-ce qu'on renonce à la retraite
systématique pour les étrangers plus de
65 ans qui n'ont jamais cotisé en France
je ne le crois pas donc tant qu'on
arrêtera pas les pompes aspirantes il y
a des gens qui probablement souffrent
économiquement dans l'organisme et se
dire on va en France on sera dans ce
texte vous voyez ce qu'il n'y a pas
encore on ira en France on sera logé
nourri blanchi et personne jamais ne
pourra nous c'est donc on en verra ce
signal là rien ne sera réglé sans voter
la globalité du taxe vous pourriez voter
certains amendements par exemple j'en
suis un qui pourrait être déposé par la
majorité même si les arbitrages sont pas
encore fait qui proposeraient l'idée
d'un permis de séjour à points
c'est-à-dire qu'en fonction du niveau de
diplôme en fonction de la connaissance
de la langue française vous auriez plus
ou moins de points et donc une plus
grande facilité avoir un permis de
séjour est-ce que ça pourrait être une
bonne mesure le gouverne enfin la
majorité dit c'est pour avoir une
immigration plus qualitative et ne plus
être dans le quantitatif bon alors c'est
quelque chose
ça veut dire qu'aujourd'hui ces de
sélection n'existe pas et ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui le gouvernement reprenait
qu'on a une immigration qui n'est pas
qualitative qui est quantitative et
effectivement puisqu'on a atteint tous
les records 470000 personnes entre
légalement chaque année en France et on
ne compte pas les illégaux qui sont
estimés à 700 000 par Monsieur Darmanin
lui-même déjà c'est un premier pas quand
on reconnait ses tort c'est aller dans
le bon chemin mais excusez-moi on parle
essentiellement là de l'immigration de
travail quand on parle de qualitatif etc
l'immigration de travail sur les 470 000
que j'ai citées tout à l'heure 450 000
ça dépend des années c'est 8%. donc on
parle de réduire un peu une petite
partie de l'immigration légale on est
loin du compte on est très loin du
compte et surtout qu'en face il y a une
mesure qui nous est annoncée c'est la
régularisation des sans-papiers qui
travaillent donc tout ça est un jeu de
du titre de séjour provisoire alors ça a
changé au fil du temps mais là encore
attendons de voir et puis vous savez en
France en termes d'immigration ce qui
est provisoire
ne l'est jamais c'est en général à vie
donc une fois encore on essaye de
changer le papier cadeau en nous disant
bah finalement vous allez voir on va
sélectionner mais on parle du plus petit
chiffre parmi les plus petits chiffres
non le problème de l'immigration
aujourd'hui il est clair c'est qu'on a
une immigration massive non contrôlée et
que personne une fois qu'il est sur le
territoire français ne repart donc on
aura pas réglé ce problème tout le reste
honnêtement c'est de la fioriture et
puis
monsieur Darmanin semble oublié qu'en
France il y a plus de 5 millions de
chômeurs soit des Français soit des
étrangers avec le droit de résidence et
de travailler en France réglons ce
problème avant d'essayer d'avoir de la
main d'oeuvre étrangère réglons ce
problème
il y a plein de chefs d'entreprise qui
ne trouvent pas bien sûr de travailleurs
eux-mêmes de faire appel à de la main
d'oeuvre étrangère vous savez ce qui
s'est passé au Royaume-Uni quand les
règles se sont durcies il y a je crois
deux ans sur la possibilité pour des
étrangers de travailler au Royaume-Uni
le secteur de la restauration qui était
là-bas aussi un secteur sous tension qui
employait beaucoup
étrangère a eu quelques mois compliqués
et puis ils ont augmenté les salaires et
une main d'oeuvre locale de d'anglais se
sont mis à travailler dans la
restauration avec une augmentation des
salaires à peu près de 9%. et bien nous
ce qu'on dit c'est qu'un chef
d'entreprise qui augmente les salaires
de 10 %. c'est 10 % sont exonérés de
charge patronales ça rend le métier plus
attractif et ça permet de donner de
l'emploi aux Français qui quand même
doivent avoir une forme de priorité chez
eux ça paraît assez naturel un monde sur
Adrien puisque il est député il reste
député puisqu'il exclut de démissionner
c'est ce qu'il dit ce matin dans un
entretien La Voix du Nord il dénonce à
lynchage il a été condamné hier à quatre
mois de prison avec sursis pour des
violences en version épouse vous
comprenez sa position elle est belle la
gauche morale ces donneurs de leçons qui
du matin au soir analyse au fait gestes
pour vous critiquer qui définissent ce
qu'est le bien et le mal en général le
mal c'est les autres et le bien c'est
eux et bien au moment où il y a
l'épreuve des faits c'est-à-dire où l'un
d'eux et pour le coup jugé pour violence
envers une femme alors là rien ne se
passe vous savez c'est un peu comme une
secte la France insoumise tout ce qui
grâce à l’intérieur finalement et
pardonner aux membres de la sexe
qui a suivi voilà la personne a été
exclue du mouvement de nos groupes de
toutes ces fonctions c'est clair et pas
pour deux mois pas pour deux semaines
quatre mois du groupe nous c'est des
films non bien sûr que c'est pas
suffisant je trouve que la France a
insoumise là envoie un signal terrible
qui est finalement un manque de
conviction qui est finalement une forme
de cynisme ils sont là pour être élus
ils sont pas là pour défendre des causes
moi je pense à toutes ces néo-féministes
de la France insoumise qui passe leur
temps sur le plateau à nous expliquer
qu'il faut et elles ont raison
d'ailleurs de le dire sur ce point-là
protéger les femmes faire en sorte qu'il
n'y ait plus d'agression et quand c'est
un des leurs et bien à ce moment-là père
tous ses principes rappelez-vous tabouaf
qui était ce candidat présumé
puisqu'il a été démis ensuite de sa
candidature aux élections législatives
pour la France insoumise qui dont on a
reconnu des violences et des agressions
il y a pendant des semaines il y a eu du
déni oh non on dit ça parce que c'est
une c'est un propos racisme mais le
brave homme n'a rien fait ici il avait
fait quelque chose mais ils l'ont
couvert monsieur catenins qui est
considéré par Monsieur Mélenchon comme
quelqu'un de digne de courageux qui a
toute son affection enfin honnêtement
que ces gens arrêtent de donner le son à
la terre entière et qui se les applique
à eux-mêmes la défense de Monsieur katna
si je peux me permettre me semble assez
critiquable il explique que finalement
sa femme l'a bien cherché parce que
c'est ce qu'il dit grosso modo qu'elle
avait été assez dur qu'elle avait des
propos durs avec lui
enfin excusez-moi le sous-texte c'est un
peu ça il explique qu'il y a que qu'il y
a une espèce de complot d'État contre
lui avec un manque un manque de modestie
terrible honnêtement tout cela n'est pas
sérieux la loi ne l'oblige pas à
démissionner la morale peut-être devrait
l'inciter à réfléchir c'est toute
l'hypocrisie de la France insoumise qui
transparaît là alors il y a un débat
auquel Adrien katnas ne participera pas
c'est celui sur la réforme des retraites
indéfendable d'abord c'est pas le modèle
social français qui est un modèle
solidaire fraternel qui dit que nos
anciens prennent vie de travail ont le
droit à un repos mérité et à profiter de
la vie c'est pas une logique comptable
c'est une logique humaine qui est
derrière les chiffres du comité
d'orientation des retraites ne sont pas
aussi inquiétant qu'on veut bien nous le
dire il y aura effectivement un déficit
de l'ordre allez faisons simple de 10
milliards pendant quelques années mais
milieu des années 2030 on repart à
l'équilibre et nous sommes aujourd'hui
bénéficiaires donc il y a une espèce de
pont financier à faire entre aujourd'hui
et demain qui est tout à fait finançable
alors a-t-on attaquons-nous au vrai
problème mais un gouvernement qui a
augmenté de 600 milliards la dette lors
du dernier quinquennat ne devrait pas
s'inquiéter de cela le gouvernement
annonce quand même des efforts sur les
carrières longues sur la pénibilité ça
vous incite pas à revoir votre position
sur le texte mais non nous notre
proposition elle est claire vous avez
commencé à travailler avant l'âge de 20
ans forcément vous avez eu un métier
plus dur plus pénible parce que moins
qualifié probablement et donc 60 ans 40
annuités pour les autres au maximum 62
ans 42 annuités c'est
la plupart des cas bien sûr ça arrive
non mais une fois encore nous on est
très clair sur notre programme il y a
l'âge de départ minimum à la retraite à
62 ans ce que je peux vous dire c'est
que pour l'ensemble de nos concitoyens
avec cette réforme il partirait plutôt
qu'il ne parte aujourd'hui ça c'est déjà
une garantie mais voilà le sens de la
réforme vous savez pourquoi madame borne
engage cette réforme parce que contre la
vie du médaille il faut le dire contre
la vie des syndicats contre la vie de la
plupart des parties de d'opposition
pourquoi elle l'engage parce que le plan
de relance de l'Union européenne
demandez des gages au gouvernement
français pour avoir ses 40 milliards et
que l'un des gages donnés par monsieur
dussoft était une réforme des retraites
la vérité c'est celle là et c'est
seulement celle-là madame borne n'agit
pas pour l'intérêt des Français mais
elle agit pour obéir à Madame
vanderlione et ça c'est grave
juste sur la réforme des retraites
Olivier Marleix c'est le président du
groupe LR à l'assemblée a annoncé qu'il
déposerait une motion de censure si le
l'âge de 65 ans était maintenu dans la
réforme vous pourriez la signer vous
avez vu par le passé que nous pouvons
signer d'émotions de censure qui
viennent d'ailleurs nous pouvons même en
déposer et je pense que si cette réforme
des retraites fait l'objet d'un
entêtement de la part du gouvernement
envers et contre tout envers des
logiques j'allais dire politique envers
des logiques économique et bien nous qui
déposerons nous-mêmes probablement une
motion de censure mais vous savez
capable de voter les autres la majorité
ce serait la salle des LRS et si et si
elle nous convient nous pourrons la
voter pour construire avec ce type oui
qui vient d'être élu président des
républicains est-ce qu'il fera un bon
président des républicains de votre
point de vue rassemblement national nous
avons un bon président qui s'appelle
Jordan Bardella qui a été élu avec une
très large majorité sur un projet je
suis pas sûr que tout le monde puisse en
dire autant
moi j'ai pas à m'occuper des affaires
des républicain est-ce que vous pourriez
discuter avec lui est-ce que c'est plus
facile de discuter avec Eric Ciotti
qu'avec Christian Jacob à l'époque ou
l'Eric ciotique il y a aux dernières
régionales en Provence-Alpes-Côte d'Azur
appelé à voter pour Monsieur Muselier
soutenu par le gouvernement plutôt que
pour Monsieur Thierry Mariani ancien
ministre de Nicolas Sarkozy soutenu par
le rassemblement national tout cela
n'est pas très logique moi j'ai pas
envie de m'adresser à Monsieur sciotti
d'abord c'est pas mon rôle mais je
m'adresserai plus tôt aux électeurs moi
et aux militants des républicains si
vous aimez profondément la France que
vous voulez plus de sécurité moins
d'immigration et une politique
économique plus raisonnable alors
rejoignez-nous travaillons ensemble le
vrai parti qui vous ressemble c'est nous
aujourd'hui les républicains c'est un
globe un club de notable qui pour
certains au pire vont à la gamelle pour
d'autres essaie tant bien que mal de
survivre en univers hostile mais c'est
clairement plus une force de
gouvernement
merci d'avoir été notre invité c'est
franchement rock elle a une de la
dépêche une fin de Lyon très beau titre
Christelle Bertrand
merci Christelle merci Laurent jacobelli
on passe au club de territoire